can we show the video
of the uh the new york city
uh riders oh actually
here we have
where rioters are disrupting
uh i believe patrons of
a restaurant frightening them breaking
things
driving them out chastising them
publicly
and that was in new york yep that's in
rochester and then can we see the
march in new york
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is that the chant about burning all the
precincts down yes every city every town
to the ground and then there was a death
to america a
banner in there so this is sort of
announcing uh
what their plans are now i've heard
people say that this is
being funded by those who want trump to
win
uh certainly possible on the other hand
you don't need that because the
numbskulls who hold this anarchist
ideology are perfectly capable of saying
insane things like this in advance of an
election either as an accelerationist
move or just out of pure stupidity but
um
the point is they are setting us up for
a trump win
one way or the other one way or the
other and uh
i think we should increasingly expect it
and i think those who think
that that's the end of the world should
start thinking outside the box because
you know what
your party [ __ ] up your party
delivered you an answer that you can't
beat them
yeah no that's that is unfortunately
right
um let's let's
riff on this from 1984 for a couple of
minutes wonderful shall we
uh page
three okay everybody turn your hymnals
to page three
uh i don't know why books are paginated
this way it says page five but it starts
on page three so
early in 1984 the famous and
important book by george orwell written
in 1949 originally
i think yep um
we have the ministry of truth
mini true in newspeak was startingly
different from any other object in sight
it was an enormous pyramidal structure
of glittering white concrete soaring up
terrace after terrace 300 meters into
the air
from where winston stood it was just
possible to read picked out on its white
face and elegant lettering the three
slogans of the party
war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance is strength
those are the three slogans of the party
um that we hear about in the rest of
this
uh unfortunately prescient book war is
peace freedom is slaver ignorance's
strength
so my claim is that we have achieved two
of these three
that we are now regularly hearing
that war is peace not in those terms
but the term mostly peaceful as we have
covered here before
basically means that anything you know
any one who wishes to portray violence
as peaceful
simply has to emphasize um
the percentage of time or the percentage
of locales or whatever metric you want
to use
to game the statistic means that it is
peaceful so if you could show
once you show that headline i sent you
and then
show us the document on which it space
so here the guardian and you can find
this in
many different publications nearly all
black lives matter protests are
peaceful despite trump narrative
report fines so it is trump that is
portraying these things as violent
um and so um you
i have a couple of screenshots from that
doctor yeah please show them okay
uh so here an overwhelmingly peaceful
movement actually turn this off for a
second zach
um before we go there this this document
let me see if i can find it is
sorry um
just published um it's called
from september 2020 okay you can show
this now zach for just a moment
um this is demonstration some political
violence in america
new data for summer 2020 uh and
it presumes to be a
very measured and careful sort of data
forward data centered type analysis
turn turn off my screen framework zach
and let me just show a couple of
screenshots from
uh from this here we go an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement
it concludes the vast majority of
demonstration events associated with the
blm movement are non-violent i'll show
you the map in a minute
in more than 93 of all demonstrations
connected to the movement demonstrators
have not engaged in violence or
destructive activity
peaceful protests are reported in over 2
400 distinct locations around the
country
violent demonstrations meanwhile have
been limited to fewer than 220 locations
under 10 of the areas that experience
peaceful protests
in many urban areas like portland oregon
for example which has seen sustained
unrest since floyd's killing
violent demonstrations are largely
confined to specific blocks
rather than dispersed throughout the
city here they reference
the um unassailable source that is cnn
as if that is is going to be trustworthy
here and here
is one of the maps
of of of their conclusions
this is an organization that says that
they share all their data but
interestingly
none of these data are appear to be
findable on their site at the moment so
it's really
hard for me to figure out how it is that
they have assessed
how many demonstrations there have been
for instance or whether or not the
demonstration type has been a protest or
a riot
in portland for instance there have been
i can't remember the numbers but
you know some some number of nights the
the nightly thing that goes from
relatively peaceful to
really really not which has been like
clockwork every night
some number of those by no means a
majority and certainly not all have been
declared riots by the police
um but to a observer thinking does that
look like a riot to me
pretty much every night there's been
something somewhere in portland that
looked like a riot
how many of those were actually called
riots now we have on this map
you know big orange circle that is
orange over portland which suggests that
there were yes indeed a lot of riots
but without access to the data we have
no way of assessing
how it is that they concluded these
numbers oh and i
suspect that their use that they do not
invoke the term
riot based on the behavior that they
invoke it based on whether a riot has
been declared and i can tell you
one of the things i learned watching the
protests here in portland
was that there are all kinds of things
that are clearly a riot that the police
do not declare a riot for some reason
that has to do with the way they're
policing them
but lots of violence goes on outside of
the category right
but also if you can go back to that um
map the map okay here we go
yeah um you can also see that even the
idea of peaceful protests is a phony
story
because mostly what went on was the
growing of gmo corn
right that's not a protest that doesn't
even involve people
right so they're selling this well
they're very focused on the idea that
protests were a big story
but protests are a result of the news
bias
in favor of protests you haven't seen
the growing of corn reported
on the news but on a percentage basis
you can see based on this map a large
amount of that territory
is dedicated to the growing of crops
which you almost never hear about so
i honestly have no idea what you're
talking about i'm using their rubric
right where they're going to declare
stuff peaceful because
you know they haven't gotten around to
the rioting yeah for example
and my point is the idea that we focus
on
you know you and i will focus on the
fact that as i think every night but
one for the last 90 some has involved
violence in portland
that would suggest a large percentage of
what goes on in portland is like the
run-up to violence or violence itself
right but the idea that it was mostly
peaceful because there were many hours
in which there was no violence
there you know the city is
overwhelmingly not involved in any
protests whatsoever
a lot of peaceable eating of breakfast
burritos right my point is an intuitive
rubric here or the point is
huh there's been violence every night in
portland for the last 90.
that sounds kind of unusually violent
right
rather than oh it was mostly peaceful by
what rubric
and my point is if we're going to do
everything by this mind-numbing
you know statistical analysis that
pretends to be quantitative on the basis
that most of what it was was not violent
you know as i pointed out on a previous
live stream um the uh the
motorcade in dallas in 1963 was
overwhelmingly peaceful
i mean you know why anybody even reports
on the violence is hard to understand
clearly bias in reporting right and my
point is um
you know the same analysis suggested
what's being ignored is the growing of
corn
um in favor of news that focus on
protests
because there's a lot more growing of
corn than there is protesting
you think it's the corn lobby that's
behind us oh geez i fear my point has
been lost but
um but yes uh so anyway back to the
point
the point is war is peace
um this is a statistical version of that
right mostly peaceful is
uh a way to ignore the violence
right now um ignorance is
remind me freedom is slavery is the
second one and ignorance is strength
yes ignorance is strength we have also
achieved this one
right shut down stem the enlightenment
is a white
thing logic is is a tool of
white oppression math is a tool of white
supremacy math is a tool of white
supremacy
all of these things are an attack on
reason right and so they are an embrace
of ignorance
obviously for what purpose for the
purpose of wielding power
so here we've got two of the slogans on
that pyramid
and we've fully achieved them now
freedom is slavery
i don't think we're quite there yet but
we're headed there
right we're definitely headed there
because um what we have
are people putting other people through
struggle sessions on the basis that what
comes out of this
will be the liberation that we all seek
right through the admission of things
that aren't true so
i don't think we have quite as clean an
example on that one but at some level
we know that we are engaged in the
process that orwell
was responding to because the
match between the things we are now
contemplating
and the slogans on the pyramid which
seem beyond
you know ridiculous um the match is just
too damn close
[Music]
you